new at four governor steve sisilak's big
spending spree today he held an unusual
off-year state of the state speech
outlining more than one billion dollars
in new programs while drawing some sharp
criticism from the republican side
politics now host john langler was
inside allegiant stadium for this event
and has the latest john kirsten good to
see you 1.8 billion dollars that's how
much federal pandemic relief money
governor sysolak has to spend across
nevada today we learned where most of it
will go
for governor steve sisolak allegiant
stadium is the culmination of what's
right in nevada and why he says the
future is positive quite simply because
of you
the state of our state is resilient and
getting stronger every day normally
these speeches only happen before a
legislative session this year there
isn't one what there is is a huge pot of
money the governor plans to spread
around the state ultimately this is
about making life better for the people
we love governor sisalek has 1.8 billion
dollars in federal pandemic relief money
at his disposal today he revealed plans
to spend it proposals include 500
million dollars on affordable housing
500 million dollars on high-speed
internet 160 million dollars for child
care four billion dollars for roads
incentives for teachers and pay raises
for nevada state police that's real
progress but we can't let up senate
republican leader james settlemyer was
unimpressed spending money is not
leadership this money will be spent to
grow the government's size but with no
thought of how to fund that growth when
the money is gone
governor sysolak and his team say almost
all of those proposals are actionable
meaning they'll get through the interim
committees up in carson city he also
pledges no new taxes